the internet reproduces and sometimes
even reinforces
certain patterns in the public affairs
discussion that are persistent in the
human being
and do not fit well with those
prophecies of the cyber utopia how can
we adapt to this environment in which
evidently internet is not going to
disappear
let's move to
a more citizen-centric
view of the internet let's stop
investing money
time and other resources trying to force
citizens to be
what
they probably don't want to be
rational participative involved
committed with public affairs when the
huge majority of citizens are emotional
and engaged and basically lazy if you
allow me to say that way with public
affairs it took twitter one year to send
out a billion tweets so the first one
billion tweets were sent out in a year
the same number of tweets are now sent
out every three days i believe
governments and institutions today have
the ability and the tools and the
opportunity to create news to not have
to always go through intermediaries i
believe the boundaries between being
open and being closed have shifted and
the boundaries between transparency and
secrecy have shifted we're getting there
but there are still a few things wrong i
think or things that happen eu
communication
namely
i think it's too often focused on
process not the substance it's also a
lot of times very self-congratulating
and a lot of times just simply
incomprehensible and and way too navel
gazing in terms of of what you're trying
to say
if we mutually
explore each other the public sector and
the civil society we can proactively
co-create a media environment which
allows best practices exchange inclusive
decision making and public services
co-production mechanism
is
who did create the the expression arab
spring or twitter revolution facebook
revolution this is the mainstream media
not the internet this is the press and
the television it's not the internet the
internet is is a place it's like a bar a
square you have people that are
discussing stuff but you don't have
somebody who is editorially taking the
discussion out i'm convinced that social
media are tools the content of social
media are the people
the human being needs to be at the core
we are connecting people we shouldn't
just focus on the process sometimes you
have um
social media uh taking up uh from from
traditional media in the case of the
arab spring but we've also seen things
the other way around we are not dealing
here with things which are against
representative democracy
this is a compliment and an aid to
representative democracies the moment
when somebody else says that you are
doing a good job that's the moment when
i believe you the moment when you tell
me you're good doing a good job that's
when i will become critical
very simple principle but today that's
what's going on in the world and that's
where social media
comes in and you know puts word of mouth
on uh on speed we can manage word of
mouth and the the starting point of
creating positive word of mouth of your
organizations is the inside part of the
organization it's it's the company
culture we don't have to be boring
because we're in government when it's
about social media it doesn't a tweet
doesn't have to look like a press
release in 140 characters and then with
all those smart small worlds that the
norman normal person cannot understand
anymore let's make it more with pictures
the first thing we all need to do is to
define which mountain we're going to
climb on and after that once we know the
amount we're going to climb on let's
focus on the next step